okay get ready to get scared
Asylum and hotel fears Halloween season
has returned again to Meadows Mall oh
man Candace Charles has a live look
inside Candace good morning to you last
time we saw you you were frightened
beyond belief how are things now are you
okay everything's okay
um I've drank some water
I'm gonna be okay I've had a few breaths
I'm now in the Asylum though I was at
the hotel before Dr Vander apparently he
was supposed to be walking through this
with me as you can see is now dead so uh
I'm gonna go through this door here I'm
trying to see if the Asylum is doing
okay if it's actually a good operation
and we're gonna be talking to some of
the patients hopefully uh none of them
hop out at me uh here's one of the
patients dolly dolly what happened to
the doctor it's our Asylum now it's our
Asylum they thought they could cure us
they can't
as you can see they're all a little bit
out of their minds
thankfully this as far as I'm gonna go I
think because I'm just in the beginning
of the Asylum this is as I said 20 years
after the original story so now it is Dr
V's nephew that is running at the Asylum
but as I told you he's dead now and the
patience unfortunately taking hold of
this so you get the chance to enjoy this
whole entire story the hotel and the
asylum
Thursday through Sunday starting at 6
30. tickets are starting at 25 and then
when you get closer to Halloween it goes
up so you definitely want to check in
and see all of that
um coming up I am going to go a little
bit further in the Asylum and show you
guys a little bit more hopefully I will
stay compost uh John Heather
oh yeah
[Laughter]
wow so wow it's early to be that that
animated yeah possessed Candace and
Candace you said if you can you can
quote enjoy this uh Thursdays or
whatever it was enjoy isn't the word I
would think of not for many no but
clearly all right we'll catch up with
Candace a little bit here thank you
good job and relax okay
um